Anthony: It turns out psychopaths don't lack
empathy.
Lee: They're just regular jerks.
Anthony: Anthony here for Dnews, with Lee
Newton again from Sourcefed.
Lee: Hi!
Anthony: Oh hello again.
So you know, Lee, one of the things that we've
always thought about psychopaths is that they
lack the ability to feel empathy.
Lee: Uh, do you remember when you slammed
the door in my face earlier.
Anthony: No I do not.
Lee: As recently as 2011, studies show that
your garden-variety Dexter or Hannibal, had
the same difficulty accessing parts of the
brain responsible for emotional functioning,
as people with frontal lobe injuries.
But now they're thinking that that's not the
case.
A study published by the University of Groningen.
Anthony: From the Lord of the Rings.
Lee: No no.
Just from the Netherlands.
Says that psychopaths can access those emotions
just fine, they just need to be trained to.
Anthony: 26 control subjects and 18 criminals
with psychopathy were hooked up to a say with
me now...
[Together] fMRI
and asked to watch clips of hands touching
in either a painful, loving or neutral way.
In a control group neurons associated with
the mirror system in the brain fired off.
It's been speculated that that's the part
that lets you watch someone do something and
understand it.
It's important for learning and for empathy.
In the eighteen psychopaths, none of that
stuff fired, as expected.
Lee: The team asked them to watch again and
asked every time to try and imagine how the
people in the videos felt, and the mirror
system actually turned on.
The team believes that means people with psychopathy
copy could potentially turn on their empathy
at will, and maybe even train that empathy
into the same automatic response that most
people have.
Anthony: Other scientists say it's kind of
a jump from seeing activity in a section the
brain and then actually feeling an emotion
that's associated with that section.
And even if these guys could feel empathy,
what would make them decide to consciously
try to make a habit of it?
Lee: Well Dexter did it.
Anthony: Dexter is not real and also he still
kills people.
Lee: Dexter's just a single dad trying his
best man.
Anthony: Fair enough Lee Newton.
Hey, Lee Newton you are here instead of Laci
Green.
Lee: I am.
Anthony: And Laci Green is on Sourcefed.
Lee: Instead of me.
Anthony: Ok so if people wanna see Laci Green
over the next couple days, where do they go
to do that?
Lee: Sourcefed.com
Anthony: There you go and you can subscribe
here for more Dnews.